hi I'm Erik Bosse and Captain Marvel has
given us a first look at the one ray of
hope teased at the end of Avengers
infinity war with brie Larson is Carol
Danvers Captain Marvel coming to
theaters in March 2019 the Marvel
offseason is officially over folks who
are we kidding Marvel season is
year-round baby that's the thing about
Marvel fanboys we're always hungry let's
break down all these images where all
the big details that you might have
missed and spoiler warning in case any
of these predictions into being too on
the nose
okay let's start with these first images
shown in Entertainment Weekly we see
brie Larson on the magazine's cover and
a promo image and we finally see Carol
Danvers and Captain Marvel's signature
blue red and gold suit from the Marvel
Comics so just to give some backstory
here Carol Danvers was an Air Force
pilot who gained her powers from a Kree
warrior known as Marvel the Kree are an
advanced alien race known for
militaristic prowess and they're locked
in a war with another alien race called
the scroll whom we'll get to in a bit
the older comics Captain Marvel is a
male character with Carol being known as
Miss Marvel but in recent years the
relaunch of the character passed on the
Captain Marvel moniker to her and that's
the director in this movies going go sow
Carole's fists are glowing here those
are among her powers she can fire energy
beams from her hands she can also fly
and she has super strength and
durability and she can anticipate wind
attacks are coming in a may have seen
how the promotion for this movie keeps
describing her as the most powerful
Marvel hero and it's true when it comes
to pure power Captain Marvel's actually
at the top so this promise of her
fighting back against Thanos is
something we should definitely feel good
about real arson and the co-director
described Carol Danvers character as
headstrong reckless and messy quick to
jump on things not always waiting for
orders and it's that stubbornness and
insistence on leading the charge that
could make her a difficult team player
for a group like The Avengers which
already has a captain from a past era
who's accustomed to leading the charge
and not probably in orders mmm-hmm
let's move on to the next image we see
Carol Danvers in her green cream
military suit the one that we've seen
other leaks set photos so one
interesting detail revealed in this
magazine feature is that while this
Captain Marvel movie will be set in the
1990s it's not a traditional origin
movie they said that when the movie
opens Carol Danvers already has her
powers so like recent Marvel solo films
like Spider Man homecoming and black
panther Captain Marvel won't spend its
whole first act following the tropes of
that noir
human bean becoming a superpower and
human being it'll actually just start in
the middle of the action though I
wouldn't be surprised if flashbacks into
bemused so careless with the star force
here it's an elite military team on the
Kree planet holla
the directors describe it as the SEAL
Team six of space joining Carol in this
star force is core F remember Djimon
Honsou scare achter from the guardians
of the galaxy we also see Jemma Chan she
was in the movie crazy rich Asians and
here she's playing Minerva in the comics
she's known as dr. Minerva a Kree
geneticist they're walking up to Jude
Law's character he's the leader of the
Star Force and a mentor figure to Carol
along with Ronan Lee pace remembered the
Kree villain from the guardians of the
galaxy more on him in a bit next is this
image of lost character and Carolyn
check out their clothes along Carol's
leg appears to be some kind of alien
language hard to tell but it looks kind
of like the Kree alphabet which has
shown up in agents of shield and the
guardians of the galaxy breakout ride at
Disneyland so if any of you out there
are creams ladies let me know what it
says in the comments below next is a
shot of the villains of this movie the
scroll there the alien race of the Kree
is warring against and they're known for
their shape-shifting ability here
they're washing up on this Beach making
me wonder if this could be Hawaii which
is now the home to the Inhumans which do
many Kree origin we'll see if they show
up in this video
now the one of the left is their leader
Talos played by Ben Mendelsohn the
villain from ready player one rogue one
and the Dark Knight Rises we get a
better look at the human form that Talos
shape shifts into in the next image and
the article reveals that he has
infiltrated the ranks of shields which
by the way along with Hydra that makes
two enemy organizations that have
secretly taken over a supposedly super
secure government entity now in the
Marvel Comics these kind of scroll
agents are the main threat of the secret
evasion storyline which a number of
well-known Marvel heroes are secretly
replaced by scroll shapeshifters this
causes paranoia and doubt to overtake
the Avengers now I have a theory for how
this could affect the MCU but first
thanks to our sponsor Ventura watches I
think it's safe to say that my time here
at new rockstars has kind of been a
gradual evolution to make me a less
cringing monster to sway back to you
know so them I'm more confident when I'm
shouting at you guys about Skrulls and
you would be amazed how much this watch
from then Sarah just completes your look
and elevates your games just so classy
and well crafted with nice finishing and
attention to detail and it's still
portable plus you know it's not that
minimalist cookie cutter design that all
these other sheep were wearing look with
this you stand out you get noticed even
if it's you know people reminding me
with the movie theater to correct your
pronunciation of Marvel from a recent
video actually it's moving but hey nice
I see face and that crocodile finished
navy blue leather band and Sarah
apparently just received their eleven
thousand five star review in their site
a lot of people are liking their
luxurious style and I'm one of them just
check out their site for yourself for
their variety of designs and colors
there's really a good fit for anyone who
wants to look their best and we are
doing a special offer just for you guys
click on the link below and use the
discount code rock stars for 15% off
your entire order ok back to this idea
about the squirrels secret invasion
shield
if literally any shield agent could be a
Skrull shapeshifter in disguise
I predict that this Captain Marvel movie
will do something similar that Captain
America the Winter Soldier did with
hydras take over shield that's right
retcon trusted characters that we've
seen before as secret scroll imposters
just imagine the paranoia who from the
MCU could actually be a scroll in
disguise look at a new secretary Russ
anyway let me know what you think about
this theory in the comments below next
we see laws character again and Ronan
know I'm Solomon guardians of galaxy he
was an outcast from the Kree for his
extremist views a rogue agent of the
Kree government actually disavowed but
here in this movie set in the 1990s he's
still a high-ranking member of Kree
society assuming this movie will show
his fall from grace then there's this
image of Carol Danvers just a street
clothes but look here actually reminds
me a lot of caps inconspicuous look from
Winter Soldier here she's wearing a hat
with shields logo and her shirts is for
the 90s band Nine Inch Nails actually
rains me a lot of Tony's throwback Black
Sabbath shirt next is a very interesting
shot a digitally D aged Nick Fury it's
just amazing how Marvel's VFX department
was able to give Samuel Jackson back his
other eye you'll notice that he does
have an interesting scar over that eye
which makes me think that whatever
damaged his eye might already be in the
process of damaging it perhaps he had
some implant or maybe poison that's
gradually eaten away in it remember fury
actually alluded to the origin of his
missing eye back in Winter Soldier
soldiers trust each other that's what
makes you too normal not a bunch of guys
running around shooting gun
last time I trusted someone I lost an
eye I guess is that the shield agent he
trusted was Talos the scroll in disguise
and the last two images show Carol
Danvers is an Air Force pilot in a
fighter cockpit she's joined by her
friend whose name you could see on the
side of the plane
maria rambo callsign photon actually in
the comics there's a character named
Monica Rambeau aka spectrum she has also
gone under the name Captain Marvel as
well as photon and pulsar she has
similar powers to Captain Marvel she
actually led the Avengers for a period
of time it's looking like Maria might be
introduced in the present timeline
through her mother Monica in the 90s
what a question I'll leave you guys with
do you think Captain Marvel will be the
biggest game-changer in the fight
against Thanos and Avengers 4 or could
some other a technological breakthrough
by characters like Sheree or Tony Stark
be the main key to his defeat comment
down below with your thoughts and follow
me on twitter and instagram at EA vas
for other cool stuff I'm working on like
this video share around subscribe the
new rock stars for all the big Marvel
updates that you need to know about
because when brie Larson tweets
promising to break the Internet we are
the hungry hungry hoax who smash it